the optics of this
play directly into donald trump's
narrative of a city
under siege protesters pulling down the
fence
surrounding the federal courthouse but
those doing this
are a minority
behind them are thousands of peaceful
protesters
marching for black lives matter exactly
two months on
from the killing of george floyd but the
movement has morphed into something
different
the intervention of federal troops
igniting an
anger that wasn't here before i'm not
going to go and be violent
i'm not gonna go try to like hurt anyone
i don't think anyone else is really out
here for that either
but people are very frustrated
to better understand the reality of
what's happening in portland we need to
show you what it looks like here during
the day
a protest camp opposite the court has a
sense of peace
and permanence and the numbers are only
growing
the irony of it is that more and more
people are coming out
to support locals and to get the feds
out i mean moms are here now
a call to arms by one portland mother
saw 2
000 respond they now form a protest wall
each evening the feds being here is
ridiculous and so
i feel that we need to make a stand and
show this not allowed
in our town or in the us for that matter
when i say left that means your left
puts it in the deck veterans now march
as a group
too as to a newly formed contingent of
nurses
far from the anarchists donald trump
describes
but with a violent minority it can be a
confusing picture
and the legalities of what's happening
here are complex
too federal troops are legally entitled
to protect federal property like this
courthouse
but it's highly unusual for an
administration to send in law
enforcement
without the invitation of local police
and each night at the moment
agents in riot gear are pushing
protesters
several blocks back and that is
stretching the legal limits
of what they're allowed to do
[Applause]
protests have dwindled to just a few
hundred people before the arrival of
federal
officers here they far from restored the
order the president pledged
but the scenes that have followed may
well play into his campaign
of law and order sally lockwood sky news
portland